ED ANUFF: So I'm going
to talk to you today.
So first let me
introduce myself.
I'm Ed Anuff, head of product
strategy at Apigee at Google.
And what I'm going
to talk to you today
about is this idea of
API first thinking,
how you should think about your
APIs, those digital products,
some of the different ways that
APIs get shared and reused.
And how you need to think about
APIs as part of an ecosystem
rather than just simply
as a way that you
are exposing your applications
as digital services.
So, one of these--
then there's me, let
me skip past that--
generally when we talk
about API first thinking,
what we mean by
that is this idea
that the starting
point of your APIs
shouldn't simply be what you
have in the database, what you
have in your application
server, or in an enterprise
context, what you have in
your enterprise service bus.
But really starting
from this idea of,
what are the experiences
that you're trying to power?
And what we see in
sort of traditional IT
and also I think from sort
of a first order thinking
that most developers who
approach this problem come at
is to say, I have this stack.
I have this application
that I built.
I've got perhaps a legacy system
that I want to make available.
And so APIs are just simply a
way that I expose this service.
And depending on how I'm going
about thinking about my API
program, perhaps maybe
I'm assembling an API team
or maybe this is more of an
informal micro service context
and I'm just sort of
sharing in an ad hoc way,
these are the services
I have available.
But generally, there's this
idea of what at Apigee we would
call this digital value chain.
Which is that you're exposing
these services and a variety
of participants, developers
go and use these APIs
and build applications.
And they ultimately may show up
powering a set of applications
that a user actually
interacts with.
And API first thinking
basically reverses that.
And it goes and says, OK,
there are a set of experiences
that I need to deliver.
There's a set of partnerships
that I want to build.
Perhaps I want to create
new types of business models
that are made possible by APIs.
And I need to start
with that end in mind
and design my APIs
to meet those needs.
I need to think about what
the developer experience is
going to be.
I need to think about
what the terms of service
are going to be.
And I'm going to craft an
API program around that.
And most people that we see
start from that previous slide.
But the really
successful API programs,
the companies that you
see that are actually
based on APIs, so we all
see companies like Twilio
and Stripe that have been
very successful in building
API based businesses,
they start in this way.
They start thinking about
the developer experience
and they start thinking
about as much as possible,
the user experiences that these
APIs may ultimately power.
So, given that that's the
case, why don't we do?
This why doesn't
everybody do this?
Well, the answer is there's a
lot of different types of APIs.
In fact, there are really three
different ways of viewing APIs.
And one of the things
that I hope you take away
from this presentation is
whenever the API discussion
starts up in your
development teams
within your company, in
whatever context people start
talking about we should
pursue an API strategy,
start to ask some
questions about what
do we mean by these APIs?
Because there's at least
three different forms of APIs.
There's APIs really from
a service perspective,
whether we're talking
about new style
micro services or old style
service oriented architecture.
There's APIs as interactions.
And then there's
APIs as products.
And we'll look at each one of
these in this presentation.
And all of these APIs
exist within ecosystems.
That is the fundamental
truth of an API
is that it is designed
to share services,
share data, connect
experiences between systems,
between applications,
between people.
So you have to think about
the ecosystem consideration
regardless of what the purpose
is, which of these three types
of APIs that you're building.
So, APIs as services,
if you're a developer,
if you're within IT or
whether you're in a startup,
this is the area of
APIs that I think
most developers
sort of intuitively
understand because it's
what we live in, what we--
it's how we build our
software these days.
But these APIs take a
lot of different forms,
even within this context.
The main way that
most developers end up
interacting with
APIs is in order
to get to the back end resources
that their applications need.
And what we see is that if
you're building an application,
you need access
to data, you need
to be able to interact with the
outside world perhaps via email
services.
Most people are not going and
using their company wide email
server to send out their
email interactions.
They may be connecting
to an enterprise service
bus or some form of
integration architecture
if they're part
of an enterprise.
Those of you in the
platform as a service space,
if you're using Cloud Foundry,
if you're using Heroku,
this idea of the
12 factor model is
going to be very familiar
to you and this idea
that your application
workloads can
scale better if you separate
out the stateful services
and treat them as
external services.
So this might be a
way that you come
to start thinking about APIs
because this is how you're
going to get your
data or how you're
going to get it your
storage or perhaps even
to an external service.
And obviously, there's a
whole set of companies,
Google included-- this is the
nature of the Google Cloud
Platform-- that are providing
you with a set of capabilities
that are going to be used
to power your applications.
Interestingly enough, in
the enterprise space--
and some of you are in
enterprise space, some of you
are in the startup space--
we see a big divide.
In the enterprise space,
most of these services
that we talk about are probably
sitting behind your firewall,
perhaps in your own data center.
Whereas if you are doing
Greenfield new development
if you're a startup,
hopefully you
are getting these
from the variety
of awesome databases of service
or storage service choices
that you have.
But even if you're
doing this internally,
you're still thinking this way.
We see very few companies
that are going and approaching
building new internal services
for their applications
where they're not now
thinking about saying,
how do we make these
RESTful services, how
do we make these API based?
And in fact, increasingly going
and using the popular developer
portal type of format of
allowing internal developers
to discover and use these APIs.
And there's a lot
of interesting work
that's being done here to
replace this ESV approach.
In the Cloud Foundry world
and the Kubernetes world,
there's this concept
of a service broker
that provides a better
level of mechanism
for integrating these services.
Now inevitably in
these conversations,
we get questions
about micro services.
And in fact, at Apigee as
we interact with customers,
this becomes the most
common topic these days.
Which is wait a
minute, we're talking
about doing micro services.
What's the difference between
APIs and micro services?
And also by extension,
what's the difference
between micro services
service oriented architecture?
So there's a lot of
definitions of this,
of micro services
that float around.
The one that I would
have really stuck
to when people would ask
me what the difference
between micro
services and so is,
is to really talk about the fact
that micro services are trying
to solve a scalability problem.
They're trying to solve the
challenge of decomposing
your application into
independent units of work that
can be scaled at appropriate
levels, the right container
instances for those workloads.
Each one can be elastically
scaled independently.
Micro services
generally are not meant
to be a mechanism of reuse.
Again, the best analogy
to micro services
are, we took the components
of the spring world
and now we're laying
these out into containers.
It lets us do things like
have polyglot programming
within our development teams.
These are all good reasons
to use micro services.
Not to say that you can't do
micro services for the purpose
of sharing and
reuse, but you need
to understand you are going
to pay a penalty in terms
of agility the wider you cast a
net of your service dependency
graph.
The more people who
depend on your services,
the more you will
translate from being--
or transform from being a very
agile application development
team, which may have
been the way you started
this journey, to being
a service provider who
now has to worry about a whole
bunch of other considerations.
And it becomes a full
time job in and of itself.
These are the ecosystem
considerations
I was referring to
previously, which
I'm going to get into
a little bit more depth
later in this presentation.
So the next form of APIs,
and this really throws
a lot of people for
a loop, is this idea
of APIs as interactions.
And in fact, as we've
worked with enterprises,
and most enterprises really had
embraced this idea of service
oriented architecture
in the early 2000s,
and there were a
set of blueprints
and patterns for reuse
that designing services--
the level of service
granularity and so forth--
really were encouraged
as best practices.
Those proved to be
anti-patterns when you
went to move towards mobile.
And they actually further
hampered a lot of people
as they tried to
embrace things like IoT.
And there were a number
of reasons for this.
But the idea was
that these services
that you use to power
front end interactions
look very different
than services
that you use to expose
back end resources.
They are purpose built.
These experienced APIs--
that's a term that Netflix
coined to describe these
and it's caught on for people
who sort of study different API
design patterns--
look very different
than the services
that are designed for wide
reuse that perhaps you're
using when you're
building a back end
service that you want to be used
by many different applications.
And in fact, the lifespan
of these is very different.
In the mobile world, you further
compound this with the fact
that many mobile
developers, if there's
no SDK to access these APIs,
consider the API incomplete.
And so that's why
when you see companies
that are trying to succeed
with mobile developers,
if you look at--
for example, Firebase
provides a real first class
mobile experience.
They do so by providing very
well-built SDKs that developers
can easily integrate into
whatever IDE environment
that they're using,
Xcode, what have you.
They've put a lot of thought
into this developer experience.
Most API developers, most API
architects that I talk to,
they sort of want to
push as much as possible,
this SDK problem
off to the side.
You do see some good approaches.
A lot of the popularity
of Swagger now, open API,
has come about because it allows
you to express these APIs a way
that can quickly be accessed
via SDKs, client libraries that
can be auto generated
from the APIs.
Now experience APIs
add a new wrinkle
in that some of these
again are purpose built.
They are not designed for reuse.
They may be built by your
front end developers.
So you may have one
team that's building
your APIs for general
reuse but you've
got your web developers who are
building single page apps who
need special APIs to
power those experiences.
And you may have the
aforementioned mobile clients
that again, needs specific APIs
to power specific experiences.
Anybody who goes to a shopping
site, you go to Amazon,
you see a Buy It Now button.
Obviously downstream,
you are going
to go and have an inner API that
handles the payment processing
but there's going to be
a separate interaction
or experience API that's
powering that Buy It Now
button.
This is not an anti-pattern.
You can have multiple
forms of APIs
to power multiple
forms of interactions.
The way you do that is by
having this mediation layer.
And so, companies that are
building user experiences
around APIs have some
form of mediation layer.
That might be something
that was built in Node.js.
In fact, a lot of the popularity
for Node has come from the fact
that because it's JavaScript,
because JSON is the native data
format, it's a great
place to go and basically
create this mediation tier that
can go and take this back end
inner API that might've been
designed for general purpose
use and create these small
services that are purpose built
for perhaps a specific
interaction when user hits
a button on your mobile app.
The role of API
management platforms,
if you want to know why do
a lot of companies deploy
technologies like Apigee?
API management platforms provide
this mediation layer type
mechanism.
And so, this might
be a reason why
you find yourself looking
at that sort of product
or technology.
So the third aspect of
APIs is API as products.
And this tends to
really separate out
the thinking from those
two previous instances.
In the scenarios where
you're thinking about APIs
as services, it's
really your developers,
your software
development team leads
that perhaps are thinking
about what services are
being designed for wider reuse.
In APIs as interactions, it's
probably a front end team.
But now you've got the
scenario where you go and say
I want to build a business
model around APIs.
And in that case,
what you're doing is
you're really
thinking about how you
are going to manage
these APIs as products.
And this tends to trip
people up because there's
a number of different folks
involved in building APIs.
You've got your developers
that build the APIs.
You have a set of people
who are testing them.
You have a whole set of
operational concerns,
whether you're doing sort
of classic enterprise style
centralized ops
or whether you're
using more of a DevOps
focus, you still
have a whole set of
considerations around that.
Now you've got to
think about how
you manage this API lifecycle.
And what we've seen
is that companies
that are successful
with this have
somebody in the role
of API product manager.
And it's not always
a full time job.
It might be part
of another role.
But there is
somebody whose job it
is to make sure that all aspects
of the API lifecycle and most
importantly, the
critical metrics that
determine whether the
API is succeeding,
are being looked after.
So when you're
productizing an API,
suddenly you now
have considerations
and if you're this
API product manager,
you're very focused
on your API design.
If you're building a
payment processing API--
we've got a number of
customers that are offering
payment transaction gateways.
If you're the product
manager of one of those APIs,
you're going and
saying, how can I
provide a better
developer experience
than someone like Stripe?
And the way you're doing that is
through superior documentation,
perhaps better client
SDKs, and you're
looking at the design
of the API itself.
Is the amount of parameters I
have to send or these payloads,
are they the right size?
Are they easy for developers
to wrap their heads around?
Or do I have to
consider and send
a lot of data that
really doesn't make sense
for my application.
That's where API
design comes in.
Is it properly designed
from RESTful best practices?
A lot of new security concerns.
One of the things
that we've seen
as we've been in a lot
of these API hackathons
is that the biggest
challenge people have,
developers in using a new API
is getting the authentication
right.
It's a big problem.
Simply just going
and saying it's
OAuth isn't always the solution.
There's still a
lot of things that
need to be improved
in getting developers
to be able to understand
and be able to go and make
a cURL call that allows
them to actually get results
from the API.
And then the last piece,
and this is probably
the biggest set
of considerations
that the would be API product
manager needs to think about,
is the metrics for success.
This is the difference
between APIs as a product
and just APIs as a project.
Your metrics for
success from an API
are going to be different,
depending on your business.
John Musser, the founder
of ProgrammableWeb,
several years ago
made the observation
that I agree with,
that you need to--
regardless of the context
of what your APIs are for,
you need to go and think about
the classic marketing funnel.
Some of you are going and
saying, hey, I'm building APIs.
Does this mean I'm
a marketing person?
Well, not necessarily.
But you have to think
about how people
are going to be adopting
these and every step
that we're going through.
And so he identified a set
of metrics and a process
that goes along with
those metrics from finding
developers, perhaps
promoting your API.
It gets picked up
on Hacker News,
it gets found via
Google searches,
people are tweeting
about it, what have you.
You're getting them to
go to a developer portal.
They're signing up for it.
They're using it
within an application.
You've got active usage of that
API within a number of apps
that they shipped.
Perhaps you've got monetization
associated with it.
This is going to be
different for you.
Everybody's API
business is different.
Some of this won't apply because
you're doing internal APIs.
But even in internal
API ecosystems,
there will be a set of metrics
that you need to manage to.
This is what it means to be a
service provider because you
need to know your customers.
And in order to provide
quality of service,
you need to be basically
managing to these metrics.
So, hopefully these three
forms of APIs make sense.
Hopefully for those of you who
are involved in API projects,
you're able to think
about and map what you're
doing to these types of APIs.
But what I want
to talk about now
is the ecosystem
that the APIs sit
within because this is where
things really get interesting.
It's not as simple as just
going and saying my exposing
my API is REST or I
see this GRPC thing.
What are the technical
considerations?
Do I use a gateway
with caching or not?
All of those requirements
are very important
but it's the ecosystems
that your APIs are used at--
used by that really is the whole
reason why you're doing this.
Most businesses do
operate within ecosystems.
If you are a company that is
becoming a digital business,
you probably are already moving
many of your supply chains,
your value chains to
be digitally mediated.
And that might be what's
driving your API thinking.
You may internally,
within your IT processes,
those represent a ecosystem
and a value chain.
Most of what we're talking about
here is what the people who get
all excited about this stuff--
tends to be industry analysts,
tends not so much to be
developers and IT people--
start talking about what
your value chains are.
Well, hopefully this will
serve as a primer to that.
You generally, when
you're building APIs,
you're going to be serving
one or more ecosystems.
You're going to have
your internal ecosystems,
those are sort of the APIs
you share with your friends
on your team, your
internal developers,
but this ranges out.
There might be
partner ecosystems,
there might be
industry ecosystems,
public ecosystems.
These all have new
considerations,
new requirements.
Generally what we see
is people sort of take
this approach that I'm sorry
to say is a little naive
but that said, it's
the path everyone takes
which is to go and
say, well we're
going to build our
APIs for internal usage
and then we're going to open
them up to the outside world
and it'll be great.
Tends to-- you tend to find,
going back to my first slide,
that a whole bunch
of new considerations
hit you over the head.
Hopefully halfway through
this presentation,
you're starting to get an
inkling of what some of those
are.
But let's talk about how these
ecosystems are different.
If you're doing ecosystems
for your APIs as services,
they're predominantly internal.
These are what you're
doing to share and reuse
the applications.
You build the systems, you
build the back end resources,
you build with other developers.
There's a number of
different approaches to this.
There's the classic
SOA approach.
Now, people who were SOA
architects, SOA often--
SOA stands for service
oriented architecture.
Those of us who were around
at the time go and say,
well there's nothing
wrong with SOA.
It just simply says
we should build
as services that should
be designed for reuse
and you'll get all sorts of
productivity gains from that.
What we found was that
most organizations ended up
finding that you ended
up having to impose
a strong form of
central governance
in order to make this happen.
And there is a slippery
slope that gets you there.
And I actually believe that
about half the companies
that are embracing
micro services
are going to end up there.
The way that you end up
on the slippery slope
is just going and
saying, all we have to do
is agree to a common
set of conventions
and all of our
services can be reused.
Then nobody can agree with those
common set of conventions are.
Hence the strong central
governance model.
Now, what tends to
work is this idea
of an API management model.
An API model where
you go and say
look, I am going to expose
the API in this way.
It will be a RESTful API so all
of your clients can talk to it.
We are going to document
it in standard ways.
We're going to use the open API
specification to document it.
And I'm going to stand
up a developer portal
and that's where we're
going to find it.
And if that API doesn't
work the way you like,
then what you should do is
build your own client libraries
to access it and perhaps
use your own middleware,
if you will.
Perhaps use Node.js
if it's something
you want to build yourself
to shape and convert
that API to your use cases.
This tends to work very well.
We see that the interaction
model-- and that Node.js,
as I said before, that Node.js
model tends to be most closely
associated with situations where
these APIs need to be exposed
for interaction purposes--
this has a lot of
interesting aspects to it.
Mobile was the main
driver for this
but we now see things like
conversational computing.
We see things like if you're
using Google Assistant,
if you're using Alexa, if
you're using any of these, Siri.
You're seeing that you now have
the ability, if you actually
are delivering your services
within standard interaction
models, that they
can be now used
within these new types of
conversational interaction
models.
But we also see
that there's a lot
of business drivers for this.
Retail people look at this and--
folks in the retail
industry they go and say,
this is how I'm going to power
omnichannel interaction models.
And you find that
there's this need
to go and make your APIs
available in standard ways
so that you can actually
talk to an e-commerce stack.
You might be able to talk to
some form of direct response
email interaction
system and so on.
These tend to try--
so supporting an
ecosystem in this model
tends to try or drive
you to getting your APIs
to fit certain patterns.
Right now, I say
patterns, not standards.
There aren't as many standards
in this area as there could be.
And I think that both
of these models, people
tend not to think of
themselves as participating
in an ecosystem but I think
increasingly you're going to.
Let me talk about the
product ecosystems
because I think those are
where things get the most
interesting.
So within the
product ecosystems,
there's a variety
of different ways
that people make their
APIs available for use
by other folks.
So basically, the idea
here is that you're
taking your business
capability, you're
packaging it up as
a building block
that other companies
can go and embed
in their business processes.
So, in terms of how
you find these APIs,
right now the predominant way
that people find and interact
with APIs is really sort of this
one sided traditional commerce
model where people go and
discover the API, usually
through a preexisting
business relationship,
or they are leveraging
one of the major brands.
If I'm going and I need to
send an SMS API, the API--
there's a set of choices,
very well-known choices.
People learn about these
through conventional marketing
mechanisms.
But where things
get more interesting
is where you have this
platform oriented approach
where you actually can bring
these APIs together and promote
them and combine them
in different ways.
Some of the examples
of this that we see
are for example, if you
look at the partnership
between MindBody which is--
provides scheduling
services for things
like yoga studios, fitness
centers, and so on,
and what's happened
with Google Maps,
this is an example
of where you actually
see a two sided relationship
where both companies are
actually sharing services
and data between each other
to create two
different application
experiences with a whole
bunch of synergy between them.
So if I go to
Google Maps and I go
and I say I want to
be able to go and book
a session with a
fitness instructor,
I can go in and do that.
And Google Maps will call
out to the MindBody API
and they'll be able to
find the nearest fitness
center where that's available
and directly book it.
That's what we actually
see in the right hand
side with this screen that's
showing Reserve with Google.
I can get to this via
the map user experience.
Now the flip side of
this is that you've
got Google Maps itself
integrating with MindBody
within its application.
So if MindBody is providing
a private label application
to a specific chain of fitness
centers or to end users
through the variety of
channels that they do that,
that users are able
to go and get access
to Google Maps with all of
its location based services
but in the context of this
application experience.
So I think that
what we're seeing
very successful
within the API spaces
where you're able to basically
cross-pollinate this experience
by sharing data and process.
Some of the other
forms of this slide
are things that I
think you're going
to see more of as we look out
in the future of different forms
of ecosystems.
One of the things I
wanted to leave you
with at the end of
this presentation
is this session that I just did
is the first part of what we're
calling The Connected Business
Track here at Google Next
to-morrow Chet Kapoor,
CEO of Apigee at Google,
is going to be talking
about this vision
of a connected business platform
and how all of these different
ecosystems power different
types of business models.
And some of these business
models that we see
are actually these clearing
houses and marketplaces
for digital services and we'll
get into a lot more depth
in that keynote tomorrow.
So, let me wrap this up.
So when we talk about
API first and we
talk about API centric thinking,
hopefully this presentation
has given you kind of this
perspective of thinking
about this outside in approach.
Even if your APIs
are predominantly
being used for
internal purposes,
it makes sense if your scope
of reuse is wide enough.
If you are working with
other development teams that
are sort of beyond arm's length
where you're not scrumming
with them, where you're
not regularly interacting
with them on Slack,
you need to suddenly
be thinking about your API
consumers as customers.
Now if your APIs are designed
for being APIs as products,
then you definitely are going
to have to think about this.
The competitiveness of
your API, the success
of your API as a product really
will come down to the developer
experience that you create
and the quality of service
that you provide.
Being able to identify what form
of API that you're building--
is it simply designed
for service reuse,
is it a micro service, is
it something that's powering
an interaction, or is it
this API as a product--
is going to help you
think about how you
organize your team around it.
Where it sits within
your organization.
If it is designed
for API as a service
in that classical sense, maybe
it is something that sits--
if you're in an
IT organization--
that sits within your
classic integration
center of excellence.
Although generally, we
see and advocate people
move away from that
strong centralized model.
If it's an interaction,
it's probably
sitting with your
front end team.
But even if it is, you
now have considerations
like how do I allow
my front end team
to go and build these
interaction APIs
and make sure
they're still secure?
And if they're
APIs as a product,
then do you have an
API product manager?
This last concept of
managing your APIs
as a digital partnership,
super important.
This tends to be the light
bulb moment for most folks
when they think about
their API programs,
particularly when
you're bridging
into trying to explain
the value of APIs
to the business folks
in your organizations.
Suddenly when people
understand an API is
a digital partnership,
they understand
all the responsibilities
and opportunities
that go along with that.
And finally, regardless
of how you are using APIs,
you have to think
about the ecosystems.
The nature of the
ecosystems will
be different for each
one of those APIs.
But ultimately,
the moment you've
got one other person beyond the
person who built their API--
built that API using
the API, you now
have an ecosystem that you need
to cultivate and grow and make
successful.